foreign
things like we're just we're very
different when it comes to our interests
in trying to find ways that we can both
enjoy things we like and share
experiences with each other have them
exactly outright said that I miss them
I knew you hadn't said that
[Music]
what up what
up John the Dr John delone show
I'm so glad that you are with us we're
talking about relationships and your
mental health and even your physical
health and whatever's going on in your
life
um this show is serves one purpose and
that is
for you not to feel so alone as you're
trying to figure out what happens next
what happens next and the wheels fall
off when you're struggling with your
mental health when your partner cheats
on you whatever's going on in your world
this show is real people going through
real stuff in real time and my promise
is I'm gonna sit with you and we're
gonna figure it out and I'm I'm always
grateful to the brave callers who call
in and say I've never told anybody this
before but this is what I've done this
is what I'm experiencing and also I'm
really grateful for you all for your
feedback and for reaching out if you
want to be on this show if you want to
be one of the callers that makes up this
show the show doesn't exist without you
give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 and you leave a message
let us know what's going on and we'll
give you a buzz back or go to John
deloney.com ask a s k all right uh
you've got a questions for humans I do
it's time for our oh yes ten dollar
sales still going on don't miss this
because they're gonna go back up and
then we got some new decks coming out
they're gonna be expensive get all the
ones you can at 10 bucks nice go for it
today's question
what's something you're avoiding right
now oh geez
and answering this question can't be the
answer
Andrew you got to go first
ah there we go oh thank you Joe uh
apparently turning my mic on is what I'm
avoiding right now excellent I don't
know I've been thinking about this for
20 minutes I don't I'm really avoiding
anything oh you pregame them
I'm sorry that's not cool man thanks
Andrew sorry Kelly wow fun Ruiner Kelly
it happens you guys have these eloquent
typed out answers and I'm here going
all right so you're not you don't seem
like a guy that avoids anything you're a
welder for God's sake you just like go
do what needs to be there's things like
we need to buy a toddler bed for my
daughter I'm avoiding that because that
crap's expensive
I don't know that's what I got
where where's just just where's your
toddler sleeping now
in our bed Oh I thought you're gonna say
like in a nice box no we have a mattress
on the floor but she prefers the dog bed
I don't know why she has a a small bed
that she's outgrown
but she prefers the dog bed Kelly you
got to figure out how to get this team
we're trying paid better
that's all I'm saying that's all I'm
saying all right uh Christian sitting
over here in Virginia what do you think
man
I think uh I'm avoiding uh speaking to a
lot of people back home since I moved
here uh where's back home uh Malawi
Malawi in the southern part of Africa
why are you avoiding them
um because it's a lot uh starting a new
life in a new place and
um
on top of that I have got a lot of
people
um asking me
countless questions all the time and I'm
like
let me focus on getting settled and just
finding my bearings
um
I can't do too many things at once yes
you you've become
you've become like a live-action Google
for everybody who's ever met you right
yeah exactly are people asking you
um for stuff too oh yeah yeah oh yeah
like iPhones and like can you buy me
this can you buy me that I'm like
since why I never bought you this stuff
before but I am I you're an American now
and there's iPhones on trees right yeah
exactly hey if you need some cash to buy
some of your friends stuff Andrew's got
it he's got it he's not buying his
children a bed uh but he does have extra
cash he can hook you up I'm gonna hit
him up yeah thank you man thanks Joe
what are you avoiding well even though
this show is going to play at a later
date I have been avoiding paying my
taxes Joseph pay your taxes I oh and I
don't want to go
you owe this year yeah
yeah I'm sorry I'd give you a hug we'll
hug after the show there's no prize for
you to file early if you owe that's true
that's fair
I guess there's no prize at all no I
guess roads and firefighters and cops
are cool so I'll go with that but
all right Kelly what are you avoiding
uh according to my counselor
um I avoid
grief yes and feelings yeah overall
those are two things I've personally
witnessed you avoiding yeah
same way that I okay when something
happens I instantly
just come flying out you have an awesome
it just goes off yeah it's incredible
so with everything that's happened in
the last few months you know my mom of
the house everything he's like I keep
expecting you to come in here and like
if it one of these days we're gonna have
this big breakdown but it's just
on to the next thing on to the next
thing so that's what I avoid so I would
say I'm avoiding
um
oh man it's quite a lot
um I
I'll just lump it all into I've I
am back seeing a counselor for the first
time and just this new life that I'm
leaving leading is brought up a bunch of
old stuff and
um it changes the dynamic between me and
my wife and so we have been
we're both pretty smart and so we've
been talking about uh seeing somebody
together and then we called somebody and
they said yeah but it's gonna be a while
and
just we're just like cool like as though
that was the thing we needed to do right
we actually need to go do it
um so anyway because now it's probably
like well we've done that so we need to
call so it's cool yeah and so I'm
avoiding Swan diving into some I I know
it's there I know it is and kind of like
people who call the show they know what
I'm gonna say it's very much like that
like I know where this is headed and I
know it's gonna suck and I know it'll be
great on the other end but man I'm
avoiding it and I can shove it all down
with Gummy Bears it's incredible which
I'm gonna say I have seen you eating so
much crap over the past few days I've
got eight or nine like every deadline is
important right now and uh
than this yeah he walks in yesterday to
the studio doll and I just he drops like
five packets of gummy bears and it's
every time I've seen you over the past
few days you've had candy in your hand
yeah and so I'm handling I'm like here
we are I'm hanging all right I'm hanging
on man hanging on
oh way to kill questions for humans
bringing down a room all right let's go
to
um Stacy in Bryan Texas what's up Stacy
hi John how are you I'm great what's
going on
um
I mean just doing good so far
um we're just kind of ready to jump into
this question and see if you can kind of
give me some insight try let's do it
Jump On In
all right um so I will preface this with
me and my husband are definitely just in
a crazy season of life right now and
we've had a lot of
um chaos going in on our work lives um
we have a four-year-old who has had some
developmental delays a lot of chasing
um evaluations Specialists therapies
things like that and because that wasn't
crazy enough we're also due with our
next one any day now all right
all right
and so now more than ever I really think
finding time for he and I can to connect
is really important but I'm having a
hard time being able to felt healthy
expectations and boundaries around us
spending quality time because we don't
like doing a lot of the same things like
we're just we're very different when it
comes to our interest in trying to find
ways that we can both enjoy things we
like and share experiences with each
other when
um like I said we just don't really want
to sort of like doing the same things
so is your concern this picture that you
have in your head of this is what I
thought this was going to look like
or is it actual
like I really miss my husband
and you see you get the difference there
in that question
I do and uh it's probably the second one
okay
so it sounds like
the
the question you asked like how how do
we deal with expectations and how do we
like find things that we can do in
common together that's secondary too
I really miss this guy
yes
have you told him that
um I feel like I've tried okay
but I also think he struggles with the
sometimes with some of the emotions
involved in that and being able to
really sit down and be vulnerable with
me
and so it's almost like to sit down and
try and have that conversation and
sometimes I feel like he's just doing
the hit fights
I I assure you he is 100 percent
100 he's deer in headlights and he
doesn't want to say the wrong thing and
he doesn't want to do the wrong thing
and I I can just speak to my my life
um
I when we were expecting our second I I
I I was busy my wife was busy we had a
little one
I knew I was good at playing guitar
and I could get better at that so I just
started gravitating more towards that
and I knew I was good at work so I just
started working more and whenever a cool
crazy chaotic
punk rock showed go to town I'd just go
to that because I knew I would have fun
there you see what I'm saying it was
never an attempt to get away from my
wife ever it was always just a I know
I'm good over here because I'm clearly
not good over here
and that just was a matter of me not
having the tools and my wife didn't have
the tools and so we just were went and
did the things that we knew how to do
it's like my car breaking down the side
of the road and I don't know how to fix
the tires I can change the oil and so I
would just get busy changing the oil on
the side of the road and then I get done
and the oil is perfectly changed and the
car still can't drive because there's no
the tires are all flat right that's
what's happening here
um
when's your baby due
um in a matter of
about a month and a half or so okay very
cool
so give me an example of a way you've
tried to tell him I miss you
um you know I I
you know with you working so much and I
want to be more intentional about
finding time for us
um
and you know just trying to say like you
know like hey I want to spend time with
you before you know we just kind of
enter even more chaos and
I mean I have them exactly outright said
that I miss them because
I knew you hadn't said that okay here's
a here's a new way I want to reframe
this and it's what you're doing here is
you're gonna
um you're speaking Spanish and he's
speaking Italian and I'm gonna teach you
how to speak Italian for him okay okay
when you go to a guy a young dad
and I'll just Brian was just north of
where I grew up so
um or I guess it's West where I grew up
when you tell a young Texas dad who's
working 80 hours a week and his wife is
pregnant with number two
um
I just you're working so much and you're
never here
what he hears is he's experiencing the
house is on fire
and you want to talk about how warm it
is
and he's just trying to save everybody
and the only way he knows to save people
is by making money
being successful in his job
okay so here's a different way
should you invite him out
I don't want you to have a blank sheet
of paper in front of him
and what we're going to do is we're not
going to use amorphous ethereal language
like I just feel like we're not gonna do
that
we're going to speak his language and
we're going to say all right what I want
to do is map out the next 60 days
and then mapping this out I want to map
out our time together
who's going to be taking care of our
four-year-old and who's not like what
projects do you have at work coming up
let's map this thing out because what
we're going to do is we're going to
start practicing building a life
together
okay okay and so what he's going to be
able to do is go cool I can do that I
can build a thing I can I can do a task
and when you say all right we have
mapped out
um Child Care we've mapped out I'm gonna
be taking time off of my job my
mother-in-law's coming in or my mom's
coming you'll be able to put all that on
the calendar and then you'll be able to
say we don't have any dates here
and by the way you're not gonna have any
dates for the first 60 days anyway
probably
well and I say that let me take that
back
some of my most amazing memories of my
life my whole life
is we got snowed in when my daughter was
born and we had a weird crazy snowstorm
and it snowed everybody in in Texas for
a week and my wife and I and our new
baby sat on a couch and we watched all
of the series Fringe because I loved
Pacey I love Josh what's his name Joshua
Jackson yeah Pacey because I live in the
Dawson's Creek fan we just watched the
whole thing and we had a fire going the
whole time and that was some of the most
intimate time of my life just holding my
baby sitting by my wife holding her hand
getting her getting up and getting
coffee whatever we needed to get and so
that was an awesome season but we
planned it too we were pretty attention
about planning it so instead of these uh
it's gonna be no no we're gonna have
date time and it could be date on the
couch it could be date watching TV I
want to make sure we put that on the
calendar and what you're doing is you're
building in a language between the two
of you of intentionality and then in
three months or four months when the fog
starts lifting a little bit and somebody
can come over and keep your little one
for maybe two hours for y'all just to go
to dinner or something like that it will
already be built into the way y'all are
talking and one of these things might be
from this point forward
um we're gonna do something every Sunday
night we're gonna get together and talk
every Sunday night we're gonna go for a
walk every Saturday morning whatever
that looks like see what I'm saying
yeah we're gonna build those things in
now I want to answer your your original
question and not just blow it off for a
second okay
um I want to give you a framework just
using can I just use my life I know
that's annoying because we're different
people but that's the guy I know the
best here's a framework
um that I'll pass along for how do you
share experiences when one of you likes
doing one thing and one of you likes
doing the other thing
um so I love music I love live music I
love I love laying my floor with great
headphones and just close my eyes and
turn the lights off and they're
listening to all the pieces I like
listening to the hi-hat and how they mix
the drums I just kind of can geek out on
it I also like playing music a lot also
and I love chaotic punk rock and heavy
metal and I love great singer
songwriters and folk singers and I love
hip-hop and I love stand-up comedy so I
love the whole Arc and so if I look step
back and look I like noise and I like a
little bit of chaos and I like art
performed and I like being in a crowded
space with people who are all have our
eyes headed in the same direction and
we're sharing music we're laughing doing
all the stuff together okay my wife also
likes music
she likes it at a reasonable volume in a
car and she doesn't mind What song comes
next on the radio usually and she has
curated playlists I don't I wouldn't
know how to make a playlist I know how
to make a mixtape I was a gangster
mixtape but I don't know how to make a
playlist
um and so the last month I went and saw
a band called White Reaper at a tiny
little Club they were Mayhem it was
super fun
I went and saw Underoath at another club
and they were like screaming and ah and
it was just chaos
and then my wife and I went to the Ryman
Auditorium and watched a folk band that
a folk rock band that we both have loved
for 25 years
and
um I've got a show coming up like I'm
playing guitar on this thing and it was
a guitar part that I've been trying to
learn for a long time so I'm down in the
basement playing and playing and playing
she would probably rather set her
eyelids on fire than sit in a watch me
practice guitar
but I had a moment I had like a little
breakthrough and like a teenager I ran
upstairs and was like hey will you come
listen to this and I played it and she
smiled so big and she was not smiling
because her husband was going weedily
diddly on the guitar she was smiling
because she saw how happy I was that I
accomplished something right
right and she's into gardening and I
like being outside I don't understand
all the gardening things she's doing and
reading she's a great she's a way better
writer than me and she's a coach all I
had to say is this the distance we
create inside our togetherness
gives us intimacy and new avenues to get
to know each other
okay so I want you to think of you and
your husband as that ring that you wear
on your finger y'all are bound together
where can you create
pockets of I didn't know that about you
tell me more what are you learning wow I
didn't know you could do that inside of
that Circle
and so what I would tell you is
have your own things and be really good
at them and then share them
on occasion and vice versa and sometimes
you just gotta put on headphones and go
to the monster truck rally or whatever
the thing is and my wife has gone to one
or two punk shows and she sits up
against the wall and during the chaos
and she just Smiles because she's like
what are these guys doing they're just
morons and I've gone to my fair share of
country music Hee Haw whatever George
Strait came in on a horse once that's
all I know and I was there for that so
sometimes you just take one for the team
you enjoy it because you're in love with
the person and you and you love seeing
them that happy but this idea that we
all have to do the same thing together
all the time that's just a recipe for
this is going to be a disaster and my
wife and I have I've been guilty
especially of
being too disengaged from what she's
doing so there's a balance there you see
what I'm saying
yeah but you feel free to go down the
rabbit part of the problem that I think
that we've had because like I come from
the background of you at least you know
you put the phone down and you try to
participate and you try to
you know you try to enjoy what's in
front of you as best as you're able
because you don't want to feel like
you're dragging the other person down
whereas sometimes I think my husband if
we go out and do something that I enjoy
doing it almost turns into a
like he should just get credit for going
with me and if he wanted to sit on his
phone during the you know whatever it
was that that should be acceptable and
I'm like and if I'm honest I'm like that
like that hurts me that hurts my
feelings because I just want him to kind
of be present with me in the moment
you've got to say those words
because what you're asking him to do is
to be a mind reader
because he would probably rather have
explosive diarrhea than go to a knitting
event or I don't I'm just making
something up awful
um or to a 4-H event or whatever thing
you're into in Bryan College Station
and so he's gonna go and he thinks he's
making a great sacrifice
on behalf of mankind he's not going to
be one of those husbands that just stays
at home and drinks drinks crummy beer
he's going to go with his wife and thank
God for cell phones
right and you've got to take the extra
step and say Here's when we go to these
things I would love it it means a lot to
me if you're present
if you're here with me
and I don't think that the whole world
is about dropping if my wife asked me to
watch golf
like I'm huge like if she said I'm a
huge golf fan all of a sudden well I
don't know if we'd stay married if that
happened but it would be close but if
she said oh we're just gonna I just want
you to spend seven hours watching golf
with me I would have to say I can't do
that
if you want me to come down like when it
gets really awesome then I will come
give you this much time I will put my
phone down and I'll plug in you can tell
me all about golf
um but that'd be tough for me because I
don't like watching golf I think it's
it's um I think it's an Abomination and
it's it's insane
all my friends are golfers so you you
see what I'm saying I think you're
putting a ton of pressure on yourself
and you're expecting your husband to be
a mind reader don't do that okay okay
let me end the call with this
your needs are worth being spoken
clearly and out loud
and it sounds like what you're doing is
you're hedging your bets because you
don't want to run this guy off
or you don't want to be annoying or you
don't want to be a burden and you don't
want to be in the way
so as a husband from close to where you
all are right now
with two little kids
I will implore you almost beg you
be very clear about what you need and
give him an opportunity to show up
and he's gonna mess it up
and you are too
and part of your marriage is going to be
not with everything being perfect but
it's as Ester Pearl says it's the repair
part how do we come back together after
I missed it I showed up to the event and
I was on my phone the whole time and you
felt completely disconnected and I
thought I was being a husband of the
year how do we solve that problem with
back to what I said earlier we're gonna
have these Sunday night get-togethers
We're not gonna have a fight on the way
home I'm not gonna mope and be like oh
you didn't show I'm not gonna do that
I'm gonna recognize when I wasn't clear
and then on Sunday night when we get
together and say Hey you came to this
thing I'm really grateful you came
I know you're not into heavy metal music
or into calf roping or whatever is going
on
I know that
but it would mean the world to me it was
important that you came but you weren't
with me when you come I want you with me
I'd rather you not come than call me to
sit there on your phone the whole time
and we're gonna do that on the Sunday
night meetings when there's no there's
not a lot of energy in those meetings
those are planning meetings those are
fun meetings where we're dreaming about
what our life's gonna be and we're
trying to figure out how to get there
it's not going to be in the Heat of the
Moment it's not gonna be accusations
all that said good luck on having your
baby
give yourself tons of Grace give him
some clear directions Kelly I I may need
to get Sheila printed a list for me all
the way from things I'm not allowed to
say in the delivery room questions I'm
not allowed to ask and things that were
going to be cheated for me in the next
week it was so amazing it was such a
gift so great I may get that and we just
put that the show notes that is like a
template for other families
I would love to see that
you would die laughing because it's
exactly tailored to me yes it's awesome
hey everybody we'll be right back
[Music]
hey deloney here folks getting out of
debt and getting good sleep have
something in common intentionality when
you're working your way out of debt you
have to be purposeful you got to build
your emergency fund pay off your debt
smallest to largest and stick with it
all that stuff and when you're ready to
invest in good sleep you have to have a
plan too you got to get that early
morning sunlight you gotta exercise you
gotta cut out all this caffeine and you
gotta limit screen time and you have to
budget for a premium quality mattress
because it makes an enormous difference
and that's why I recommend dream Cloud
mattresses and for my friends on a
budget I have incredible news right now
dream cloud is offering my listeners 25
off their order plus 50 in additional
savings and why not 599 more dollars in
accessories with promo code John deloney
that's pillows luxury sheets and a
mattress protector and dream Cloud gives
you a one-year in-home trial so you can
make sure it's the right fit so it's
time to invest in good sleep have a
budget meeting with your spouse make a
plan and then go to dreamcloudsleep.com
and use code John deloney to get your
new mattress today that's
dreamcloudsleep.com and use code John
deloney
all right we're back let's go to Justin
in Indianapolis what's up Justin
how's it going Dr John I'm good hey uh
you're not working at that what there's
like a big fire going on there right now
huh
no I I wouldn't know anything about that
no fire here
[Laughter]
just in your heart hey that's awesome
dude okay so what's up
Hey so uh I'm 23 and I'm getting married
in July congratulations
so we are excited and um we are huge
Dave Ramsey people too so we've got all
the baby steps and all that stuff lined
up and um
so we are I work at a CNC shop and I
have unlimited overtime so essentially I
am gearing up to just absolutely grind
it out and pile up as much money as I
can so we can buy a house and do all
that stuff the Ramsay way and what's
what's a CNC
shop uh it's computer and Americans also
essentially I use crazy machines
that sounds so great
it's so much fun I love it you know what
I am I love my job I'm a podcaster
podcast is pretty cool listen to your
podcast a lot I know but you can take
machines and cut metal me that's so
awesome
ah and Angie Over Here Andrew over here
is running the board he can take that
metal and melt it together with fire I
don't know I just I I'm uh I'm
embarrassed to be on the phone with you
is what I'm saying so all right so go
ahead so you're you've got the
opportunity to just essentially
earn a ton of money by working your butt
off over the next however many months
yes and I love my job so I'm perfectly
willing to do that excellent however my
fiance has expressed concerns that she
she says she understands all the Dave
Ramsey stuff she says that she gets that
we need to you know really really buckle
down and really grind it out now in
these next coming years so we can really
get a good foundation for our family and
start things off on the right track
which is great and I'm a very blessed
man for her understanding however she
did say that she's a little bit
concerned that I might be working too
much and that she's concerned about me
being present in the first couple months
first couple years of our marriage so I
guess my question is how do I what are
some good ways to like balance
right you know really getting gazelle
intents really grinding things out and
really working hard at my job and you
know making the money to ensure our
future but also you know
um dedicating and investing in my
marriage as well
it's a great question man I wish more
people were this intentional on this
side of it usually people come to me
when their marriages are hanging on by
dental floss and trying to save it and
you are being wise and intelligent and
on the front end so good for you man for
everybody listening um if you don't know
Dave Ramsey's stuff is what he's talking
about is
um
for 30 years Dave's been teaching people
how to get out of debt to stop owing
people money and you hear me talk a lot
about the the psychological issues with
owing people money but also there's a
wealth building component there's a how
to buy a house and how to buy cars and
how to
um invest and things like that so
um you're way down the road there Justin
here's here's what I think
is going to get you all into trouble and
here's a simple path out of it okay
um have you heard me talk about pictures
and words before
a little bit okay here's uh here's a
recap of pictures and words
um is the great William Glasser who is
the psychiatrist back in the day who
actually swore off psychiatry in a way
um he he's the one who gave me this idea
we
think in pictures but we speak in words
what I mean by that is you're about to
get married and you have a picture in
your mind of what the word husband means
and in your mind I'm guessing a husband
is a guy who works really hard and he's
a provider and he looks at a goal 15
years down the road when it comes to
paying for kids college kids that aren't
even born yet
paying off a house uh making sure your
family's safe providing food all those
things
your wife has a picture of husband
of a guy who walks in at exactly five
zero zero every day who neatly puts his
clothes away and who is smelling so good
and who just sits down to a nice and I'm
completely gender stereotyping this
thing by the way and sits down to a nice
dinner and smiles and then y'all all
watch TV and she falls asleep in your
arms
now both of you
deeply love each other
both of you are deeply committed to each
other
and you are going to go a hundred miles
an hour towards your picture of the word
husband
and she is going to go a hundred miles
an hour trying to make the picture a
husband in her head possible
and y'all are both going to go a
thousand miles an hour going opposite
directions from each other
and so when you come home at seven
o'clock or ten o'clock at night having
busted your butt in a hot Warehouse in
the summer cutting metal
she's gonna be sitting home heartbroken
that she's done something wrong that her
husband rather hang out with machines
than her
and then when you come home at five
o'clock you're going to be looking at
your watch the whole time going it's
we're never going to get a home
so the magic here is not how do I find
the balance balance is an illusion is
not real that's a fake word so it's a
waste of time to go towards it what I
want you guys to do is to get really
clear and United on these pictures
here is what my picture when I hear the
word wife here's what's in my head when
she hears the word wife here's the
picture in her head
what kind of house do we want to live in
and when do we think we want to buy one
how much money would it take just
reverse engineer it that means that if I
worked 48 hours a week for the next two
years I could make this thing happen or
if I worked 80 hours for one year we
could have a house
and now what you're doing is y'all are
just weighing what kind of life you want
to live
you're not weighing that's too much work
that's not enough work you're never home
for dinner you're not all those
questions go away when you decide
together here's the life we want to have
and so for us I wanted a life outside of
higher education someday
I wanted a life where I wasn't on call
24 7 365 all the time
and so what that meant was for three or
four years I was gonna go back to
college I already had a PhD I was done
I'm gonna go back I'm gonna get trained
in something else
so that I have different options and so
what that meant was every couple of
weeks my wife and I were meeting like
this is awful I'm writing papers every
Saturday instead of playing with my
young kid and I'm reading books into the
middle of the night instead of going to
concerts and all that we gave up that
moment and now we're living a Banana's
life like a cartoon
but we sacrificed but we did it together
you see what I'm saying
so those things took care of themselves
and so I'd love for you and your wife to
sit down and say
hahaha let's let's just tell her exactly
what I told you about pictures and words
and what marriage like when I see
marriage in my head you're probably
going to default to what your parents
did she's gonna develop to what her home
life was like you're not gonna try to
make this thing work and that's where
that tension comes from
all right so speak back I talked at you
a lot tell me tell me what you're
thinking
you know marriage counseling
amazing amazing parents and we've just
come from two great families so we're
doing marriage counseling all that stuff
so we actually have marriage counseling
this evening so we're having we always
have dinner before and kind of talk
about our week and stuff so I was going
to talk to her about about whatever it
is we talked about this evening at
dinner and yeah that uh that pictures
and words that really makes sense to me
so I'm following you there awesome oh I
just I just I am desperate to give this
woman everything that she deserves
because I am the luckiest man in the
world and I love her more than anything
in the world so that's all trying to be
prepared so the greatest gift you could
give her on the front end is Extreme
clarity
about what you
often especially husbands but wives too
especially husbands
we get in our head I want to give my
wife everything
well I may have talked about this on the
show this is this is a private
conversation between me and my wife so I
don't know if I have or not
um I really want my wife to have a
handsome husband
and I can't do much about my face
I got stuck with that one
but I can stay in the gym
especially with how much how bad I eat
sometimes
and I really want my wife to never ever
ever worry about money ever
I want her to do whatever she wants
whenever she wants
and so
I'm gonna work like crazy all of the
time to always be earning always be
earning always have another line in the
water another Prospect another book on
the horizon I always want to be earning
and it was during a Christmas holiday
not this year but the previous year
when I was sick and I was down in our
little home gym lifting weights I was
lifting heavy and I can be kind of
obnoxious loud and whatever
and she came down and just said what are
you doing
I was like I'll mark it out what and she
came and got really close to me and
she's shorter than me and she got real
close and she said on a pie chart that
is our life together
the looks department is filled
the next exercise you do is not for me
it's for your ego you're welcome to stay
down here but you cannot tell yourself
or anyone else that you're doing this
for me
and she said while I'm here when it
comes to money we have enough
well I don't have enough of is you
what I realized Justin is I was using
what I thought she wanted and I was
trying to give it to her and I never
bothered to ask her
occasionally I would ask her and I
wouldn't believe her
occasionally I would be like hey and
she'd be like you look great I'd much
rather you be up with us once or twice a
week for breakfast instead of spending
an hour and a half down in the basement
and I'd be like yeah she says that now
but one day
what if I just trusted my wife
right so it goes back to asking
um and then I'm gonna give you this one
thing you're gonna find as you in as a
newly married 23 year old man yellow
young dude
um you're gonna find yourself not
knowing what you're doing
and work is going to become a great
distraction a great drug my good friend
Ian simkin says if busyness is your drug
then rest will feel like stress
if you medicate yourself with busyness
and with more work and more work and
more work resting will feel anxious
so you gotta be honest with yourself
about whether you're using work for a
season we need to earn this much money
so we can get a down payment for this
house and so I'm gonna work this many
hours for this long we're gonna get this
thing done or I miss endlessly working
forever and ever and ever amen because
I'm good at that and I'm not good at
being married right now I don't know
what I'm doing
y'all gonna have to build into your
relationship conversations and ways of
talking and if y'all will connect your
pictures together if y'all will be
crystal clear about what you're both
aiming in
man you will be so far ahead of every
couple I talk to not everyone most of
them
um be clear about your pictures make
sure your words and pictures match
and set up a plan together and then just
go get it congratulations on getting
married man let me know how it goes I'll
be right back
all right we're back it is time for
everybody's favorite lightning round
let's do this Kelly
when your producer was a hair metal fan
in the 80s
hi pot have you met the kettle where's
the music all right let's do this all
right first question so we say this
lightning round is about kids in
parenting and I don't know what's coming
nope
you know this I always feel like we're
gonna get canceled let's do this first
question how do we decide if and when
our pre-teen is ready for their own
phone
um the answer is no
ta-da
that's my that's my answer man
I no no pre-teen should have a phone
it's in my opinion I agree with you on
preteen yes no pre-teen should have a
phone period
um if a teenager needs a phone
um
it would have to be something that is so
highly restricted there's some special
phones out there and I don't know enough
about the individual companies but it
would have to be something that my kids
cannot have unfettered access to Ai and
the internet and all these insane
opinions about all this insane stuff
everything from sexuality to religion to
Whatever We complain like Psychopaths
about schools what are they teaching in
them schools and then we give our kids
freaking phones are you kidding me
what's the matter with you I would much
rather have a teacher tell my child
something that I disagree with and then
my kid come home and talk to me about it
then have the internet
millions of unfiltered opinions no we
got some blockers on our phones no you
don't your kids are smarter than you
that's my thought on phones ta-da all
right then back to being canceled all
right second question my job causes me
to work long hours how can I make up for
the lost time and connect with my kids
when I am home that's a great question
so one
I hope that there's some cyclical
seasonality to this that this isn't all
of the time 24 7 365. so uh my
brother-in-law works on the railroad so
that means he's gone at strange hours
that also means when he's home he gets
up a little bit early and he takes his
kids to school he drives him to school
he picks him up from school he goes to
performances when he's home so
um same with me when I'm on the road I'm
on the road I'm on the road uh when I'm
writing books and I have to Hole up in a
hotel for a week and get something done
like I miss my I miss my kids I then do
the best I can to make it up in other
places
um on my schedule and again I know I've
got some privilege here but I don't miss
I don't miss kids
um like theater performance I'm not
going to miss a play I'm not going to
miss a choir performance my daughter got
a part as the big rooster in her
upcoming something or other for first
graders I'm not gonna miss that so
that's gonna cost me money to show up to
that and it's worth every single penny
of it I'll also say this last night was
one of the most extraordinary moments of
my life at 3am about 3 15 in the morning
my daughter woke woke me and my wife up
she came in the bedroom woke us up and
said she couldn't sleep and I'm so tired
I got so many deadline I'm just out of
gas but I heard in her voice this deep
frustration
like I just want to be asleep and I
can't and I have I've struggled through
insomnia my whole life and I knew it I
heard it I felt it so I got up I'm gonna
get choked up here hold on I got up and
I went and got an apple
she told me she was hungry I can't sleep
whatever and I used our little apple
slicer and I got a plate and I went and
sat on her bed and we ate apples at 3 15
3 20 in the morning till about four and
we laughed so hard and she told me about
this dumb Boys in her class and all it
was a really precious time and so
sometimes we think how do I show up in
these moments we gotta go to Disneyland
we got it no dude eat apples with your
kid on her bed at 3 30 in the morning
she'll tell that story at your funeral
so
all right Kelly
I keep going over the little Dinger
sorry that's okay all right my wife left
and I'm a single dad of two daughters
what do I do when they start to reach
puberty how do I approach the sensitive
topics with them
I want to desensitize puberty
it's
like if you're a dad and you can't talk
to your daughter about your peer her
period like that's that's on you it's a
it's her body it's a natural thing it's
like not a weird strange oh good shut up
get over yourself have the conversations
if you don't know how to have the
conversations get with
um some women that you trust and ask hey
how should I have this conversation with
my daughter what's ways that you had it
in your life that you didn't have in
your life that so number one I want to
take away any weird stuff whether it's
Sons or daughters
um my wife will be able to have
particular experiential conversations
that are different than I can have with
my daughter 100 there's gonna be a
conversations that they need to go just
have by themselves awesome
but I don't need to be in my house like
oh periods that's just it's part of it
or you're growing up it's time to go get
brawls where like that's life and so
making that as weird as possible is not
weird as possible not making your
daughters ever feel like they have
something to apologize about their
bodies or they're somehow broken or
weird that's number one number two get a
couple of adult women in their lives
that they can trust whether that's an
aunt whether that's
um a teacher somebody that they trust
even offer to put some money on the
table hey would you take my daughter to
dinner well I'm trying to build
relationships with other women that I
trust because she's going to need people
to call this because she's not gonna
always want to call her dad with stuff
like that
um and so have set up uh curate
relationships with other adults in her
life in their lives that they Trust
all right we're pregnant with our first
and I'm scared it's going to change our
relationship
what can we do to keep things the same
between us I know bless bless your
hearts
it's gonna change a hundred percent of
everything all of it will be different
now
every bit of it is different
so you have two Avenues ahead of you you
can know that everything's gonna be
different so we're going on an adventure
together arm in arm and we're going to
reimagine sex and we're going to
reimagine entertainment we're going to
reimagine time and calendars and work
all that stuff
or you can almost guarantee the end of
your relationship by constantly
comparing it to what it used to be and
trying to drag it backwards and make
that happen again
because it won't it won't everything you
knew is over now
the way your husband or wife looks CH uh
uh ax but like all everything's
different now everything's different so
bless your sweet little Souls
um you can't because it's all Gonna
Change it's all Gonna Change
all right we can't get our teenager to
come out of his room
what can we do to encourage him to
participate in family activities like
eating dinner as a family or church on
Sunday oh geez okay
anytime somebody tells me they can't
fill in the blank with their kid I
always throw a flag on that you can
unhook the computer and throw it in the
freaking garbage you can take the door
off the hinges you can take all of the
desks and chairs out of your kid's room
what you want to do is you want to have
some magic hack or some magic pill so
that you don't look like the bad guy you
don't look like you're intervening but
that your son will magically just follow
a trail of of gummy bears out of his
room into the family
whatever it's not gonna happen you're
gonna have to
get your kid out of his room that's
number one number two often kids don't
like to play games with parents because
parents aren't fun to be around
they're the worst
they're always criticizing and judging
and trying to Bow up and they can't they
can't lose at a board game without
getting their feelings hurt or all
matter but so be somebody that your kid
wants to be around don't be an annoying
pain in the butt adult who always has a
lesson ready to go and always
like be somebody that you'd want to hang
out with
and make some of these things uh I
remember when I was a kid my dad told me
if you don't want to go to the church
where we all go great faith is important
to me and our family lineage go
somewhere go somewhere I'll drop you off
and I didn't realize at the time what a
big deal that was
um but what he was saying was
your faith you having deep roots in this
thing called belief into something
bigger than you are is more important
than making than our little picture of a
pretty family
um on Sunday mornings at some church
then some Olin Mills photo
that's
when your kid sees you being honest and
authentic not using him as a part of a
performance
and so if your kids won't come out of
the room you can get them out
it's just gonna depend on how much you
love them
we do the thing so we all go to church
together on Sunday but uh my son goes to
a different church for uh youth group on
Wednesday night with some friends and he
loves it that's great doesn't matter to
me all right how do you explain death to
young children
I mean that's that's a tough question is
any get
no the the
way David Kessler explains it that I
love and what I've used repeatedly is
when I'm talking to a kid about a
funeral
I will say something along the lines of
you know how when we celebrate
somebody's birthday
it's a it's our way of saying we love
you and we see you and we're celebrating
you a funeral is the same way it's us
telling them that we love you we always
will love you and we're gonna miss you
and so I try to contextualize that
ceremony
um
I'll just give you the two examples
because it's such a broad ranging
question with my 13 year old when we
talked about we had the Nashville
shooting here with my 13 year old
um we went out for a walk and I talked a
lot more open with him about what he had
heard about what actually happened about
the Proto safety protocols about how the
SWAT officers responded because I've
done SWAT trainings before and I've had
SWAT officers come get me and um so I
was able to just give him a play-by-play
and then also I was really clear about
the statistics it's probably not going
to happen it's probably not going to
happen but it does
with my daughter we went and got on the
trampoline and I laid down on my stomach
I got eye level with her so she knew her
body knew this is not a this is not Dad
lecturing this is not dad being scariest
dad being with her and so there's
something really important about body
position and
um uh eye level so that her body
uh regulates itself it gets still and it
gets slow and I asked her did you hear
about what happened and I let her tell
me what she knew
and I confirmed some she knew a lot more
than I thought she did but we're just at
a place now where we can't hide this
stuff from kids anymore so talking about
death is really important and here's the
other important part about talking about
death
let your kids see You Weep let your kids
see you be upset let your kids see you
be really really sad
because they have those same feelings
too and they need to see you have those
experiences so they don't feel crazy
they don't learn at a young age to stuff
all their feelings down and try to hide
them because that's what Mom and Dad do
no man let your kids see you cry let
your kids see you be really really
scared
um that's a gift
all right our son plays video games it's
where he connects with friends should we
limit his Play Time Each Day yes
absolutely 100 percent
um
I don't have any good data off the top
of my head I wish I did I don't have any
data on like here's too much and here's
too little
um I can tell you my house I broke down
and got a Nintendo switch for my son for
Christmas I know I did
I did
um and he gets one hour a week on
Saturdays when all the other it's it's
purely a reward thing
um
so that's how I do it
um academics are important in our house
connectivity with our family is really
important in our house and everybody
participating like my son does chores my
daughter does chores me and my wife do
chores and so the
the connectivity in our home is more
important than connectivity with friends
and
um also I don't he's he's not allowed to
do it online so that's a whole different
story there
um have you all drawn boundaries in your
house
it has changed kind of ebbed and Float
over the years
um right now Nathan is allowed to play
until six o'clock because by the time
we're usually not home
um and then that's usually about the
time I'm working on dinner so he has to
come and sit in the the kitchen and
that's where he works on homework and if
he doesn't have homework then
you just said he just we talk or
whatever yeah um but he's allowed to
play until but he plays usually you know
even because he plays online now because
he plays with
um with other kids you know but I always
walk in who's that who's that who's that
and um and there's been a couple times
where it was like I don't know that
person and that does not sound like a
kid yeah you know
um of course he's 17. now so none of
them sound like kids anymore exactly um
but we know all the people that he's
playing with but um we've just put a
time limit on it and
that's kind of a
non-negotiable yeah I think a broader
conversation that families need to have
is
why is this more appealing than
being connected with us and that's just
a it's just a helpful framing question
so as you get to be 17 there's some
natural I want to be around my friends
right and that's and we had to come to
the understanding of
we were like we'll go outside play with
your friends do this that's not what
they do yeah exactly it's just not no he
drives now so he and his friends would
they'll go to dinner or go hang out but
it's just not where they are now it's
different and so we had to kind of come
to that realization that this is where
he hangs out with his friends I've I've
had to not be an idiot is what I would
say yeah well like do you not want me to
have friends I mean that's the exact
conversation I have like like I don't
think you understand dad like I'm I'm on
the outside of every conversation here
and I love that I know how to care for
sick chickens I know that I can work a
lawnmower and a small tractor and I can
I I know how to
Harvest a deer
but man I just want to sit at lunch and
talk to my friends there's room for all
of it as long as it's in the right place
that's right and the priorities right
yes and I think maybe that's the most
important thing our family like we're
very clear how low on the totem pole of
a priority that is that is pure that is
that is marshmallows and gummy candy
um on the back end of a healthy meal
or as a way to cope yeah that's where
you're going with it I last night again
listen last night in
I was walking through so I was feeding
the dogs and I saw a bag of miniature
marshmallows and I just took a handful
I'm hanging on man hanging on all right
next question we're gonna get there all
right next question let's do it as our
kids get older I've noticed our
parenting styles are different it causes
tensions between us and confusion for
the kids what do we do
talk about it talk about it talk about
it talk about it and when you talk about
this don't go with again off-site
get out of your house go somewhere plan
to spend a few hours spend the money
even if you don't have it spend the
money and
don't sit down and say hey you're
letting those kids run all over that's
not what we're gonna do because then
your spouse has to fight you because you
just you just punched first
I know we both want to make amazing
adults and I don't like how I'm showing
up right now for the kids
and I'm hearing them be really
disrespectful to me and I'm seeing them
be disrespectful to other people
we got to come together on our parenting
stuff and I'm gonna put my stuff on the
table first I'm struggling what are you
struggling with or are you struggling
with anything and hopefully there's some
your your spouse has some ability to be
reflective and say like yeah I don't
know what to do here I'm struggling with
this but let's reimagine this thing
together if you get into an accusation
War then your parents parents are going
to pick sides kids can smell that a mile
away they're going to pick sides and
it's just gonna be this divided house
don't do that
how do you balance 30-second hugs and
asking your daughter's permission to
touch her
um I default to her saying no so her
autonomy over her body trumps my
um
uh
my understanding of the importance of
skin to skin contact I will say this
um I think I talked about this on the
show but my wife called out several
months ago
um
this idea of if you weren't so hard to
be around if you weren't so electric all
the time if you weren't always lecturing
all the time and saying like why are you
wearing the shoes why you got that shirt
on why are you doing
if you would be fun to be around
um that would change
and I tell you what I've worked really
hard on that and it has been
transformative in my house
and so it again using what happened last
night I could have said go to bed it's
three o'clock in the morning
uh we'll do it in the morning
I just got up and for those of you
wondering yes I ended up missing my
workout I skipped my workout I barely
made it to work and I'll be chasing
deadlines all day
I spent an hour on my daughter's bed not
even an hour 40 minutes eating apples
chilling listening to her she told me
stories
um
man the hugs on the back end of that
will come the hugs on that will come but
I'm always going to default too she is
chiefly in charge of her body
all right last question by the way that
also is for uncles grandparents
everybody everybody
why don't you go hug Granddad no she
says no Then she says no what's another
what's another way you could tell
Granddad that you're glad that he came
what's another way you could tell Uncle
whoever because her body is saying that
guy is not safe and I don't want to hug
him cool all right go go for it all
right last question my daughter does
competitive gymnastics she wants to quit
but I think she should keep at it
because she's talented and she could get
a scholarship
do I make her keep competing
who
I'm gonna speak my concerns out loud
okay
on its face no
you should not continue to make your
kids keep competing at a highly
competitive level with this imaginary
idea that um your kid's gonna get a
scholarship especially and you've got to
be really honest with yourself and most
parents can't do this
especially
um we used to call we used to call it
the soccer mom scholarship and when I
was working in higher ed here's why
I could give a student a ten thousand
dollar
um my college could give no scholarships
and I'll make up a number here a fake
number because clearly this isn't true
and our total tuition was ten thousand
dollars for the year
College down the street their tuition
was twenty thousand dollars but they
would give your kid
um a one thousand dollar JV soccer
scholarship
so the total out of pocket is 19 Grand
on this school 10 grand on this school
95 times out of 100 we lost that student
to the more expensive school so that
parents could go around and tell
everybody that their kid is on a soccer
scholarship
it's all part of the enrollment game
and so if you want to be the parent of a
scholarship athlete you need to check
yourself because you're about to lose
your kid
I will also say
as a youngster I tried to quit several
times
I was uh
big Tech big super 5A Texas high school
football player and I went to track I
went to college on track scholarship I
tried to quit both and my parents said
no
but they let my brother quit and I
remember challenging them on that as I
was older and they said y'all are very
different people
you needed the structure you needed
other adults because you weren't
listening to us to push you harder than
you thought you needed to be pushed and
it wasn't for scholarships was it was my
parents saw a developmental need that I
needed that they couldn't provide and so
they wouldn't let me my brother on the
other hand
was it was amazing like he was a
structured human being he still is he's
amazing we're very different people and
so they were able to look at him and say
he's not going to need the same
structure here and here's the catch the
kicker
um I let my kid quit one sport but he
had to choose something else to do he
can't just sit home and do nothing so
cool you do not have to do competitive
this anymore what is the sport and what
is the instrument you're gonna you're
gonna choose and so if they are like Oh
I thought I could just do nothing and
hang out with my friends that's not
gonna happen you gotta do something
it doesn't have to be competitive this
or that or this or that and mom and dads
you can always like uh what I saw on
Instagram the other day it was uh every
dad thinks I just worked a little bit
harder as high school I could have made
the NFL no you couldn't no you couldn't
you know I know you could so don't put
that on your kids if you just worked a
little harder you can go pro they're not
going pro they're not going
um so give them some peace there
good
that was great cool nice work lightning
round we'll be right back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show so
man this song was one of my favorite
songs growing up but it was redone by
the by the great Ugly Kid Joe
if you don't know who Ugly Kid Joe is
man you need to get right with yourself
um but it was originally written by the
great Harry Chapin not Chafin like I
worked out in jeans and I got chafed
it's Harry Chapin
and the song's called Cats in the Cradle
and it goes like this my child arrived
just the other day and he came into the
world in the usual way he probably need
to say that
um but there were planes to catch and
bills to pay and he learned to walk
while I was away and he was talking
before I knew it and as he grew he said
I'm gonna be like you Dad you know I'm
gonna be like you
my son turned 10 just the other day he
said thanks for the ball dad come on
let's play can you teach me to throw I
said not today I got a lot to do and he
said that's okay and he walked away but
a smile never dimmed and he said I'm
gonna be like him
well he came home from college just the
other day so much like a man I just had
to say son I'm proud of you can you sit
for a while and he shook his head and he
said with a smile what I'd really like
to add is to borrow the car keys see you
later can I have them please
and I've long since retired and my sons
moved away and I called him up just the
other day I said I'd love to see you if
you don't mind he said I'd love to Dad
if I could find the time
he was going to be just like you
your kids are watching everything you do
foreign